we are cleared for landing in gridiron  Heights and welcome back to football  everyone you like that do you like that  we remind you this is a non-smoking  league doing great Iceman just got a  lamb this bad boy like we've practiced a  thousand times before no problem coach  can you give me a read on the approach  vectors  looks like we're turning from 28 degrees  west headed towards 3 degrees that's 28  to 3 but what's that 28 to 3 and perfect  conditions there's no way you could  screw this landing yeah totally  oh you all right  oh there's one spot there a quarterback  who can land this plane  oh no sorry like a real quarterback  sounds like a jab though smoking chick  and my wife's brother I get this see I  hurt my thumb I'm done